I've been feeling like T-Pain last year
feature crazy feature crazy nowadays
let's say major label calls some it's a
new artist they signed you have no idea
who it is but they're on Atlantic and
they want that blast sauce that [__]
what's that heading for uh you know I
never charge for a future ever ever No
so you're doing it only if you truly
want I truly like the song you have to
like the song you have to like the
artist yeah I'm talking about up front
it's a back-end cause but if I like the
song I'm not going to give you that
hassle you feel me the back end is just
like the bag or is it the maybe it may
be the video the club it may be the the
Wardrobe for the video you still gotta
show up as blast I'm still a brand I'm
still a company but on the front end I'm
not going to be like I need 15 just to
record the first I need you know yo it
sucks too because a lot of artists will
pay that and then this song doesn't get
clear yeah they got the money already
hey get your money how you get it
couldn't be me though